[موسيقى]
في هذه الغابه التي تكسوها اشجار الصنوبر
والخيزران يعيش 200 نوع من الحيوانات 40
منها مدرجات من القائمه الحمراء للحيوانات
المهدده بالانقراض
في حديقه
حيث الحفاظ على الحيوانات هو اللغه السيده
150 عاما يسهرون على ذلك في الكواليس دون
اي كلل ولا ملل على مدار الساعه التحدي
الاكبر للمهمه يبدا من خلال اطعام هذه
الحيوانات كل اسبوع يستقبل المطعم ثلاثه
اطنان من الفواكه والخضروات ستكون الدببه
سعيده
بقدومك اضافه الى اكثر من طن من اللحوم
بكل انواعها
تستقبل كل شيء
لاطعام دب بني ضمن وجبه واحده طبعا
وهذا موجه لاطعام حيوان الساحل الافريقي
وهذا صندوق موجه للزرافات سيكون غريبا لو
عرفنا ان الزرافات تاكل البصل
اما بالنسبه للحيوانات الصغيره فيجب تحضير
200 صحن مخصص لكل نوع
هذا الصحن هو لاحد انواع الطيور الصغيره
التي تشبه الى حد ما الحجل الافريقي
الصغير
وهذا الصحن يحتوي على فواكه التفاح
والاجاص والمانجا
والكيوي والموز
لكل نوع احتياجاته التي نسعى الى توفيرها
له لان التغذيه الجيده كما نعلم جميعا هي
اساس الصحه الجيده
اخفض رؤوسكم تقديم الطعام للحيوانات هي
وظيفه فلور يرافقها اليوم عشره اطفال
يحاولون ولو ليوم واحد الاعتناء
بالحيوانات
سترون ما
تاكل من اكثر بالطبع لا نضع ايدينا نتركها
تاكل دون ازعاجها نرجع الى الخلف قليلا هل
رايتم ماذا اكلت اولا
العنب في رايكم هل تاكل الفواكه والخضر
فقط لا اللحم ايضا نعم انها تاكل اللحمه
كذلك هذا ياكل بسرعه ولا يترك اي شيء لقد
جاءت الانثى يود هؤلاء الصغارا يعمل يوما
ما في المستقبل بجوار الحيوانات
انها لطيفه جدا ارغب في حملها بين يدي
لكني لا استطيع ليس لدينا في ذلك اجل
في الجوار يكتشف الاطفال ان حيوانات
الراكون لها ميزه خاصه سيحمل العنب يضعه
في الماء
ينظفه ثم ياكله
هذه الحيوانات نظيفه ليس كذلك
انها لطيفه جدا حين تنظر باعينها الجذابه
اذا كان مرور فلور يسعد الحيوانات بشكل
عام فان قدوم البيطري الى ساحه الاسود
البيضاء المفضله في الحديقه كان يلقى على
ما يبدو اي استحسان لديها
تدخل الحيوانات في حاله هيجان بمجرد رؤيته
هذا الصباح يعمل الطبيب البيطري على تخدير
ثلاثه اسود صغيره السهام موجهه جيدا الى
فخذ الحيوان الذي سينام في غضون دقائق
قليله امام الاشقاء الثلاثه رحله كبيره
نحو الفلبين مغادره ضروريه من هنا لتجنب
اي صدام مع ابيها
هذه الاسود شابه هي الانف في السنه التي
تحررت فيها من والدها لذلك يجب عليها
المغادره لانها لو ظلت هنا ستتقاتل فيما
بينها لذلك فمغادرتها تجنب اي منافسه مع
والدها الفريق البيطري يستفيد من التخدير
ليقوم بعده اشياء ضروريه
نبضات القلب 64
ينزل 200 كلغ بمجرد ان يستيقظ يجد نفسه
برفقه شقيقيه في رحله 11 الف كيلو متر عبر
الطائره
مغادره تلك الاسود هذه الحديقه
يقابلها قدومه في ليل للتو من البرتغال
كان ضمن سيرك هناك
قريبا سيصطحب الفيل العجوز ميكو
[موسيقى]
لكن بالنسبه احد القائمين على رعايه
الحيوانات لا يجب السباق الامور
يكون في غضون اسابيع قليله الى بضعه اشهر
يتوقف ذلك على كيفيه تعامله معها يمضي
معها عده ساعات في اليوم ونرى كيف سيتصرف
الفيل الذكر الكبير مع الانثى
حديقه الحيوانات امني فيل هي ايضا فضاء
للتزاوج بالنسبه للعديد من الحيوانات وفق
برنامج الموجه بصفه خاصه للانواع المهدده
بالانقراض كوحيد القرن الابيض المولوده
الجديده هي ارانكا تتم مراقبه نموها عن
كثب مره كل اسبوع يتم وزنها لا خوف عليها
على ما يبدو لا يتمثل هدفنا في اعادتها
الى افريقيا بل في الاحتفاظ بنوع وراثي
سليم قد نحتاج اليه في غضون 50 عاما اذا
استدعت الضروره
الحفاظ على الانواع المهدده بالانقراض
وتوعيه الصغار كما الكبار بضروره العنايه
بالحيوانات هي الوظيفه الرئيسه التي
تمارسها حديقه امنيفيل منذ تاسيسها قبل 37
سنه